I hate putting my foot in my mouth, and it happens a lot.
I remember when I was in middle school getting ready for a dance competition, with a bunch of friends.
One of my friends emerged from the bathroom having plucked her eyebrows, and she asked...
[Eyebrow Anna]: How do they look?
[Left and Right Annas]: OMG, they look great.
[Middle Anna]: You look the same...
[Middle Anna]: What? I mean she doesn't have hairy eyebrows. Not saying she doesn't look good, I'm just saying it I can't really see a difference.
[Middle Anna]: I mean... Sorry.
Now what I think about it, I've had a very similar thing happen in high school as well.
[Sad Anna] "So what are you gonna wear?"
[Foot in Mouth Anna]: Oh, I'm gonna be wearing this dress.
[Sad Anna]: Oh my god. That's so cute.
[FiM Anna]: Thank you. What are you wearing?
[Sad Anna]: Oh? I'm just gonna wear this.
[FiM Anna]: Oh, oh great.
[Sad Anna]: Wow okay.
[FiM Anna]: No, I didn't mean like that.
[FiM Anna]: I was just like: oh my god, am I overdressed now, because you're so casual. But not like casual casual.
[FiM Anna]: I mean you look really pretty, it a really cute jumpsuit. I just um...
[FiM Anna]: I'm gonna go. I'm gonna go.
And even recently...
[FiM Anna]: Oh hey. Did you go to the dentist?
[Sad Anna]: Oh um.
[Sad Anna]: No, sorry, I I know that I need to.
[FiM Anna]: Oh no I didn't mean it like that.
[FiM Anna]: Just like last time we talked you said you were gonna make an appointment and so I was kind of just like following up...
For some reason, I just say stuff.
And I don't realize how it can be taken as offensive until I've already offended the person.
And it's like my intentions are never bad. You know, I'm not trying to be passive-aggressive. When I'm mad at you, I am very straight up about it.
[Random Anna]: Hey Dude
[Brutally hateful Anna]: Hi, I hate you and I never want to see you again.
[Random Anna]: What, why?
[Brutally hateful Anna]: I put a hex on you and your family.
[Random Anna]: Oh my god, my family, my wife and children.
I'm kind of torn between wondering if this is just a part of who I am and if I should just accept it,
or striving to really pay attention to my words and see if they can be misconstrued,
or if there's a more sensitive way of saying things. Because, on one hand, if you're my friend...
I would hope that you would give me the benefit of the doubt. And know that I'm not trying to be an asshole,
and give me a chance to explain myself. But on the other hand, if I'm your friend,
I know that I should really try not to hurt your feelings. But what about you?
Do you have a friend who's kind of like this, who always puts their foot in their mouth?
Or is this you? And if you have a friend like this...
Are you cool with them or am I just doomed? I'm Anna Akana if you have a foot fetish...
Stay here for a sponsored message.
[Sponsor Anna]: "Thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring today's episode.
Squarespace has beautiful award-winning templates. Not to mention an all-in-one platform.
So there's no install, patches, or upgrades ever.
They also have 24-hour customer service.
Whenever you're on the internet up for Yoli.
They offer a simple and unique setup experience if you don't have a domain. And they're good for any kind of website.
For feet, for other feet, for cool feet, prettier feet,
sexy feet, any kind of feets that you want.
Go to <squarespace.com> to start your free trial today and use the offer code "ANNA" for 10% off at checkout.
Feet...."